[Music]
no they are near to stay they came from
all over the country to the capital to
Washington DC to make the point that
they belong here Norberto lopez has just
graduated from California State
University I'm American I live here
since 22 years and I'm 23 years old so I
arrived here when I was 1 year old
I've lived here my whole life I grew up
here I studied here I work here
whenever I go back to Mexico they say
I'm American and when I'm here they say
I'm Mexican most of them came to the
United States before they turn 16 now
they are young students and
professionals with the Trump
administration scrapping the daca
program they may have just six months
left to clear up their studies in the
yes
President Obama initiated the program
but these demonstrators don't give him
much credit no it was not Obama who gave
birth to the daca program the community
the young people on the streets they
made a capital Obama told us several
times he can't do anything for us this
will fight over years after the
announcement today our community has
gotten even closer we know we are not
alone
so you're saying of course we're saying
valaria Mejia Guevara arrived here when
she was three years old she's now twenty
studies international relations and
speaks English Spanish French and
Mandarin
since daca she has been able to build a
life here her parents are illegal
immigrants who arrived over 15 years ago
and started a business named after her
daughter Valley Valeria's convinced that
immigrants and specially daca people are
a big bonus for American society being
an undocumented person has never been a
problem for her I have never been afraid
of being an undocumented person in the
contrary I am thankful for that my
friends gave hundred percent I always
had to give much more and that is why I
am now wearing a good as you say so it's
full scale in Uganda Valeria insists
that she is not afraid of being deported
she says that no matter what happens she
will keep fighting for her dreams people
they are telling me they are Americans
they feel American and they are not
going to leave this country the next six
months even though President Donald
Trump and the daca program the future of
these young people young professionals
is now in the hands of Congress